Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Merhaba, hoş geldiniz.
Ben bir hikâye kaydediciyim.
Kimi zaman savaştaki dramı,
kimi zaman depremdeki acıyı,
kimi zaman da başarıdaki
mutluluğu kaydediyorum.
Herkesin kendine göre bir hikâyesi var.
25 yıllık haber kameramanıyım,
şimdiye kadar birçok ülkeye gittim.
Bunların içinde savaş
ve çatışma bölgesi de vardı,
oradaki insanlarla tanıştım.
Evlerine girdim, sofralarına oturdum,
acılarına ortak oldum,
bazen mutluluklarına ortak oldum.
Zaman, mekan değişse de
karakterler değişse de
değişmeyen tek şey
herkesin bir hikâyesi olması.
Bakmakla görmek arasında bir fark vardır;
kimileri bakar, kimileri görür.
Benim işim görmek,
detayları görmek, kaydetmek
ve orada olmayanlarla aktarmak.
Benim hikâyem de İzmir'de,
1988 yılında henüz 13 yaşındayken
bir sıcak İzmir gününde başladı.
Bir yakınım vasıtasıyla, Mehmet Ali
Okumuş'tu ismi fotoğraf editörü,
Hürriyet gazetesine yaz tatilinde
harçlığımı çıkarmak üzere
Hürriyet gazetesinde çalışmaya başladım.
Okullar açılınca tekrar kaldığım
yerden devam edecektim,
orta ikiden orta üçe geçmiştim.
Karanlık odada çalışıyordum.
Karanlık oda bildiğiniz
siyah fayanslarla kaplı,
filmlerin yıkandığı,
fotoğrafların basıldığı,
içeride keskin bir ilaç
kokusunun olduğu bir odaydı.
Şimdiki WeTransfer, Google Drive,
FileZilla gibi uygulamalar o zaman yoktu.
Şimdinin kıymetini bilmek lazım.
Filmler elde yıkanır,
fotoğraflar karta basılırdı.
Bazen acil haberler olur
ve İstanbul'a acil
fotoğraf geçilmesi gerekirdi.
Karta bastığımız fotoğrafları
Telephoto adı verilen
silindir şeklinde bir cihaza bağlardık.
O cihaz, telefon hattı üzerinden
fotoğrafları İstanbul'a gönderirdi.
Bir siyah beyaz fotoğrafın
İstanbul'a gitmesi
yaklaşık yarım saat sürerdi,
dönerken de gıy gıy gıy
diye bir ses çıkartırdı.
Aradan yıllar geçti
ama o ses hâlâ kulaklarımda.
Film çok kıymetliydi.
Muhabirlere sayıyla verilirdi,
hatta birden fazla fotoğraf
yani aynı fotoğraftan birden
fazla kare çeken muhabirlere
neden böyle çektiği sorulurdu.
Her şeyin kıymetli olduğu zamanlardı.
Sonraki sene okullar açıldı,
ben yine Hürriyet'e
hafta sonları, 15 tatilde,
bayram tatillerinde
gidip gelmeye başladım.
89 senesinde yine tekrar kaldığım
yerden devam ediyorum.
İzmir Fuarı Ağustos'ta, Eylül'de açılır,
ben akşam 7-8'e kadar Hürriyet'te çalışıp
akşam 7'den 8'den sonra
İzmir Fuarına giderdim
ama gitmeden önce babamın
bir Zenit fotoğraf makinesi vardı.
Zenit fotoğraf makinesinin
içinde film yoktu,
sabahları onunla giderdim
onunla gelirdim.
Film çok kıymetli olduğu için
bana vermezler diye isteyememiştim
ama İzmir Fuarında haber yapacağımı
söyleyince bir film verdiler.
Onu makineme taktım,
fuara gittim, stantları gezdim.
Bazen güzel haberler çıkardı,
kullanmak isterlerdi.
Hürriyet'te haber girerler,
altında da "Fotoğraf: Güray Ervin"
ya da "Haber: Güray Ervin" yazardı.
Bu beni çok mutlu ederdi, yani o yaştaki
çocuk için çok kıymetli bir şeydi bu.
O gazetelerden belki
5 tane, 10 tane, 15 tane alır,
ya mahallede komşulara
ya da okulda arkadaşlara dağıtırdım.
İsmimi gösterirdim,
benim için kıvanç verici bir şeydi.
Bu şekilde de aynı zamanda
okul harçlığımı çıkartırdım.
93 yılında İstanbul'da
Kanal D televizyonu kuruldu.
94'te İzmir'de büro açtılar.
O zamanki haber müdürümüz
Cemalettin Özdoğan abim,
ilk kamera ustam Alev Parsa'ya
benim asistanlık yapacağımı söyledi.
Alev bana tripodun nasıl toplanacağını,
akülerin nasıl doldurulacağını,
ekipmana nasıl bakmam gerektiğini anlattı
ama kameraya dokunmam yasaktı,
kamera çok kıymetliydi.
Hâlen de öyledir.
Ben Alev'e yardım ederken bir yandan da
işi öğrenmeye gayret ediyordum.
Bir süre sonra İstanbul'dan
küçük bir kamera geldi.
Dediler ki, "Bu kamera senin.
Bu kamerayı al, muhabirlerle
beraber sen de işe git
ama öncesinde senden
bir video çekmeni istiyoruz."
Ben bir video çektim, bulunduğum
yeri anlatan bir video çektim.
Videoyu izledi Cemalettin abi
ve Alev, çok beğendiler.
"Tamam," dediler
"bundan sonra senin işin bu.
Hem karanlık odaya bak,
hem kameramanlık yap.
Olur mu?" Tabii ki olur,
neden olmasın.
Benim için yeni bir yol açılıyordu.
O zaman farkında değildim bunun.
Ben muhabirlerle beraber
işe gidip geliyordum
ama İzmir'de yapılacak işler belli.
Yazın konser çekersiniz,
orman yangını çekersiniz,
defile çekersiniz.
İşte kışın da sel felaketi olur,
yine trafik kazası benzeri işler olur,
devlet büyükleri gelir
onları takip edersiniz.
Benim aklımda hep İstanbul vardı.
İstanbul'a mutlaka gitmeli,
orada çalışmalıydım.
Hatta meslek büyüklerim
de hep onu öğütlerdi,
"Güray İstanbul'a gitmen lazım.
Güray İstanbul'a gitmen lazım."
Suyun başı İstanbul'du
çünkü bizim meslekte
gazetecilikte suyun başı İstanbul.
98'de bir gün yine çalışıyorum,
telefonum çaldı.
Arayan İstanbul'dan bir abimiz, "Güray
biz bir kameraman almayı düşünüyoruz.
Aklımıza sen geldin. İstanbul'da
çalışmayı düşünür müsün?"
Yani İstanbul'da çalışır mısın teklifi
sanki bana son kez yapılıyormuş gibi,
aslında ilk kez yapılan bir teklifti,
sanki son kez yapılıyormuş gibi
düşünmeden evet dedim.
Yani ne ailemin fikrini almıştım
ne kalacak yerim vardı,
ne teklifle ilgili sorular sormuştum.
Hiçbir şey sormadım.
"Emin misin?" dedi, "Eminim" dedim.
Akşam eve gittim,
anneme durumu
anlatmam biraz sıkıntılı oldu.
Hiç İstanbul'a gelmemi,
burada çalışmamı istemiyordu
çünkü İstanbul'un kendine has bir
kargaşası, karmaşası var, tehlikesi var.
Annemi bir şekilde ikna ettim, elimde
bir valizle İzmir'den İstanbul'a geldim.
İlk zamanlar çok zor geçti.
Arkadaşlarımın yanında kaldım
3 gün orada 5 gün orada,
emanet hayatlar yaşadım.
Hayatta hiçbir şey kolay olmuyor,
İstanbul'da tutunmak da kolay olmadı.
Dönüp gidebilirdim, dönmedim
savaşmaya devam ettim.
Düzenimi kurdum.
Annem sürekli İstanbul'a geldikten
sonra özellikle daha bir tedirgin oldu.
Sürekli telefon açıyor,
"Ne yapıyorsun, iyi misin?
Aman kalabalık yerlere girme!
Bıçaklarlar, döverler, ateş ederler!"
Bunların hepsi başıma geldi
ama çoğundan annemin haberi olmadı.
Ona söylemedim ta ki bir yere kadar.
2008'de Rusya-Gürcistan Savaşı çıktı.
Gürcistan, Güney Osetya'ya
müdahale etmişti.
Daha sonra, Rusya Gürcistan'a
müdahale etme kararı aldı.
O zaman çalıştığım kurum
oraya bir ekip göndermek istedi.
Bizim meslekte bazı işlere,
özellikle savaş ve çatışma bölgesine
bir ekip gönderilecekse
ilk önce gönüllülük esasıyla
gitmek isteyen var mı diye sorulur.
Yoksa ona göre bir isim belirlenir.
Bana sordular, ben yine düşünmeden
"Tamam, giderim" dedim.
"Emin misin?"
Evet, eminim dedim
ama aslında birkaç gün sonra nişanım var,
bundan kurumun haberi yok.
Ondan sonra, ilk önce annemi aradım.
"Anne," dedim,
"ben Ermenistan'a gidiyorum.
Telefonum kapalı olabilir,
ulaşamayabilirsin, sakın beni merak etme.
Ben fırsat buldukça
seni aramaya çalışacağım.
Tamam mı, anlaştık."
Sonra şimdiki eşim Demet'i aradım,
dedim ki böyle böyle acil bir iş var,
benim işte Gürcistan'a gitmem
gerekiyor, savaş çıktı.
"Ama" dedi, "iki gün sonra
üç gün sonra nişan var."
Dedim, onu ertelememiz lazım.
"Niye erteleyeceğiz?" falan.
Dedim, işte bundan dolayı.
"Hayır, gitme" dedi.
Demet'i ikna edemedim, yani ben
kapıdan giderken çıkarken bile
Demet hâlâ arkamdan
"Gitme, gitme!" diye sesleniyordu.
Neyse Gürcistan'a gittik muhabir
arkadaşım Levent Öztürk'le birlikte.
Gittikten iki gün sonra, 10 Ağustos'ta,
Gori sınırına Gori-Şinvali
sınırına hareket hâlindeydik
çünkü Şinvali'de ağır saldırı olduğu için
kayıpların, yaralıların ve ölülerin fazla
olduğuna dair haberler gelmişti.
Şinvali Güney Osetya'nın
bir sınır kasabasıydı,
Gürcistan sınır kasabasıydı.
Aracı ben kullanıyordum,
yanımda Levent Öztürk vardı.
NTV'den arkadaşlarımız vardı,
kameraman Cumhur Çatkaya
ve muhabir Hilmi Hacaloğlu.
Sabah yola çıktık, seyir hâlindeyiz.
Ne yaşadığımızı şimdi
göstermek istiyorum size.
(Arabaya darbe sesi gelir)
"Hayır, hayır, hayır!"
"Geri gel, geri gel!"
"Çabuk çık geri çık!"
(Silah sesleri duyulur)
(Silah atışları giderek artar)
"Lastikler patladı lastikler!"
"Allah eşhedü en la ilahe illallah
ve eşhedü enne Muhammeden resulullah."
"Eşhedü en la ilahe illallah."
"Kıpırdamayın yerinizde kalın!"
"Yerinizde kalın, sakin olun.
Herkes iyi mi arkadaşlar?"
"Press Press Press Press!"
Press! Press!
Biz burada aslında
savaşın bir tarafı değildik,
yani sadece savaştan
zarar gören insanların
hikâyelerini yapmak üzere
oraya giden bir televizyon ekibiydik.
O anda aklımdan neler geçti,
yani bu benim en çok duyduğum
sorulardan bir tanesi.
Bir kere kesinlikle o araçtan
sağ çıkabileceğimizi düşünmedim,
yani mutlaka aracın içinde
öleceğiz ama biz öldükten sonra,
anneme durumu nasıl anlatacaklar
nasıl haber verecekler,
eşime -o zaman nişanlanacağım
eşime- nasıl aktaracaklar,
cenazelerimizi arabada mı bırakırlar
bir yere mi gömerler,
yoksa Türkiye'ye mi gönderirler,
gönderirse kimi gönderir,
ekipmanım ne olur;
bunlar aklımdan geçti.
İzmir'de boş makineyle
yürüdüğüm sokaklar aklıma geldi.
Sokakta gazete dağıttığım,
imzalı gazetelerimi haberlerimi
dağıttığım insanlar aklıma geldi.
Benim için çok kötü bir zamandı,
aradan çok zaman geçti ama ben
hâlâ bu görüntüleri izlediğimde,
yeni yaşamış gibi hissediyorum,
gerçekten çok zor.
Allah korudu.
Biz aslında dediğim gibi
savaşın bir tarafı değildik,
insanların hikâyelerini
yapmak üzere oradaydık.
Çiğdem büyüklüğünde bir metal parçası
bir insanın bütün hayatını değiştirebilir.
Yani sizi ömür boyu
yatağa mahkum edebilir,
hikâyenizi orada sonlandırabilir
ya da ömür boyu engelli olabilirsiniz.
Sadece bir metal parçası bunu yapıyor.
Sadece savaşan insanların değil,
savaşın gerisindeki
insanların da hikâyeleri var.
Aynı izlediğimiz gibi
gazetecilerin, sağlık ekiplerinin
aynı zamanda askerlerin ailelerinin,
herkesin bir hikâyesi var.
Vurulan binaların, yanan ağaçların,
ölen kuşların da hikâyeleri var.
Savaştan bir gün önce, bu görüntüler
yaşanmadan bir gün önce Gori'de
bir hastanenin bahçesindeydik.
Hastanenin bahçesinde ağaçların üstüne
raptiyeyle tutturulmuş listeler vardı.
Listelerdeki isimleri
--işte yaralılar, ölüler, kayıp olanlar--
insanlar gelmişler, ağaçların altına
parmak uçlarıyla isimleri kontrol ederek
bir yakınları var mı onu bulmaya,
onu anlamaya çalışıyorlardı.
Bir yandan da cepheden kamyonet kasasında
yaralılar ve ölüler
gelmeye devam ediyordu.
İnsanlar bir ağaçların altına, bir de
kamyonet kasalarına doğru koşturuyorlardı.
Ağlayanlar, üzülenler;
yani film seti değil, hayatın ta kendisi.
Sadece savaşan insanların değil,
sokakta sıradan insanların
da hikâyeleri var.
Yani her gün gördüğümüz,
yanından geçtiğimiz
ama fark etmediğimiz
insanların hikâyeleri var.
Mesela yol bekçisi İbrahim Çivici.
Al Jazeera'de çalışırken
kendisinin haberini yapmıştım.
İbrahim abi günde
10 kilometre 15 kilometre
tren hattı yolunda yürüyerek
hattın kontrolünü yapan birisiydi.
Ben böyle bir iş olduğunu tesadüfen, böyle
bir meslek olduğunu tesadüfen öğrenmiştim.
İzinleri aldım gittim,
İbrahim abiyle bir gün geçirdim
sağanak yağmur altında.
Kendisinin hikâyesini yapmak istedim.
Kendisiyle röportaj yaptık.
Dedi ki, ben işte -- röportaj
esnasında şöyle bir şey söyledi:
"20 yıldır tatile gitmiyorum
ailemle birlikte.
Bir de makinistler bazen yanımızdan
geçip gidiyorlar, selam vermiyorlar.
Buna çok üzülüyorum," dedi.
Ben bunları haberde yazdım.
Haber yayınlandıktan
sonra kısa sürede çok izlendi.
Ertesi gün beni İbrahim abi aradı.
"Güray nasılsın iyi misin?"
İyiyim İbrahim abi,
teşekkür ederim sen nasılsın?
"Bugün ne oldu biliyor musun?" dedi.
Ne oldu abi, dedim.
"Bugün hemzemin geçitte görevliydim.
Koca tren, Nazilli-Söke
seferini yapan tren geldi,
önümde durdu.
Ben de arıza yaptı falan diye düşünüyorum.
Hayırdır oğlum,
bir şey mi var diye sordum.
'İbrahim çavuşum,
önünden geçip gidiyoruz.
Bazen fark etmiyoruz, gönül koymuşsun.
Duralım bir selam verelim dedik,' dedi."
(Alkış)
"20 yıldır bu işi yapıyorum,
ilk defa böyle bir şey yaşadım,
çok da mutlu oldum.
Bunu seninle paylaşmak istiyorum."
Yani onun mutlu olması
beni daha da mutlu etti.
Belki onun meslek hayatında
anlatabileceği bir anı kalmıştı geride
ama bununla birlikte,
tatile gitmesi için
imza kampanyaları açıldı.
Türkiye'nin dört bir
tarafından insanlar evlerine,
otellerine, kamplara davet ettiler.
Ailesiyle beraber tatile gitti.
Başka bir abimiz,
o da Mehmet Kadir Karamanlı.
Onunla da 2016'nın son günü 31 Aralık'ta,
Galata Köprüsü üzerinde
karşılaştım, tesadüf oldu.
Yanına gittim, kağıt toplayıcısı
Mehmet Kadir Karamanlı abi,
kendimi tanıttım,
"Konuşabilir miyiz?" dedim.
"Konuşuyoruz ya!" dedi.
Dedim, gazeteciyim çekmek istiyorum.
Tamam dedi, cep telefonunu çıkardım.
Çekmeye başladım, dedim ki:
"Bugün yılın son günü.
Siz ne yapmayı düşünüyorsunuz?"
"Her gün kağıt topluyorum,
bugün de kağıt toplayacağım
ama sen onu boşver," dedi.
Nedir abi peki, dedim.
"Bugün benim doğum günüm,
biliyor musun?" dedi.
Şimdi onu söyleyince
tabii insan daha farklı yaklaşıyor.
"Peki yani ne yapmak istiyorsunuz,
yani doğum gününüz.
Çok kıymetli bir gün, yılda bir gün.
Ne yapacaksınız?"
Ne yapacağım, dedi.
Akşam 12'ye kadar kağıt toplamaya
devam edeceğim, dedi.
"Eğer bu heybeyi doldurabilirsem, dedi
-- arkadaki çuvalı gösterdi --
benim için dünyanın
en mutlu insanı benim, dedi.
Başka bir şey istemiyorum."
"Peki kıyafetiniz çok uygun değil,
yani kış şartlarında çalıştığınız için."
"Yok dedi,
benim bütün sermayem bu,
bu da bana yetiyor," dedi.
Bu haber de yayınlandıktan
kısa süre sonra çok fazla izlendi.
Türkiye'nin dört bir tarafından
Mehmet abiye kıyafet gönderildi,
maddi yardımda bulunmak isteyenler oldu.
Mehmet abi kıyafetlerin hepsini
biriktirdi, hiçbirini giymedi
ve ihtiyacı olan insanlara dağıttı.
Bu güzel bir gelişmeydi,
daha da güzeli --
Mehmet abinin de çok hoşuna giden --
üniversite öğrencileri bir araya geldiler,
Mehmet abiyi Eminönü'nde
kaldığı internet kafede buldular,
onu aldılar başka bir yere
götürüp pasta kestiler,
doğum gününü kutladılar.
Ben de daha sonra gittim, devam
haber yaptım, Mehmet abiyle konuştum.
Kendisi çok mutluydu;
yani bütün bu gelişmeler,
benimle tesadüf karşılaşması,
hikâyesinin gelişimi, paylaşımı.
Aslına baktığımızda,
yani etrafımızda aslında gördüğümüz
ama fark edemediğimiz birçok hikâye var.
İyi hikâyeler var, kötü hikâyeler var.
Benim hayat hikâyem
bir şekilde İzmir'de başladı,
bugünlere geldi.
Umarım iyi biter, ben hâlâ savaş
bölgelerine gitmeye devam ediyorum.
Elimde olsa bizi vuran
insanlarla tekrar bir araya gelmek,
onlarla konuşmak isterim.
Oraya görev çıksa gider misin
deseler tekrar giderim,
ki hâlen Suriye ve Irak'a
gidip gelmeye devam ediyorum.
Bundan yana herhangi bir çekincem yok.
Sadece eşimi ikna etmekte
hâlâ aynı şiddetle zorlanıyorum.
Umarım sizin hayatınız, sizin hikâyenizle
başka insanların hikâyeleriyle birleşir
ve mutlu sonla biter.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)
Sağ olun.